Caption: but I'm gonna hand over to our Patrick
Caption: to talk about toxic developers and you
Caption: thank you very much
Caption: thanks for coming and seeing my
Caption: presentation on toxic developers in new
Caption: and I'm I have a quickly acknowledged
Caption: wills talk for leading into my talk
Caption: about the team and mentality and how to
Caption: build great teams like definitely goes
Caption: well with my presentation hopefully and
Caption: first things first I don't work in HR I
Caption: am NOT a team leader or a manager of
Caption: some sort I haven't studied behavioral
Caption: science and I'm not a mental health
Caption: specialist I'm also not perfect here's
Caption: what I am though I'm a front-end web
Caption: developer that deeply cares about a good
Caption: workplace culture in order to go to work
Caption: happy recently I reflected on my career
Caption: of 10 years plus in web development and
Caption: when I did that I kind of realized
Caption: there's always been one each workplace
Caption: that vina had a toxic developer being in
Caption: the form of a fellow team member or even
Caption: a superior based on my personal
Caption: experiences I would like to share my
Caption: learnings with you today what is a toxic
Caption: developer oh sorry how's this possible
Caption: I'm so sorry anyway my aim is to raise
Caption: awareness of toxic behavior in the
Caption: workplace and the impact it has on you
Caption: and your work threw me off now sorry
Caption: it's sorry what is it talks develop
Caption: let's continue toxicity by definition
Caption: means the quality state or relative
Caption: degree of something being poisonous but
Caption: there are actually a lot of different
Caption: traits a toxic developer can have and
Caption: some of them actually might surprise you
Caption: let's explore a few of them as you can
Caption: see
Caption: a lot of different trades on here and
Caption: collectively we could actually think of
Caption: many more I'm sure but what I would like
Caption: to highlight is that any of these traits
Caption: individually and in small doses does not
Caption: necessarily make a toxic developer
Caption: however someone who exhibits many of
Caption: these traits or two extreme levels might
Caption: have a more toxic effect on others given
Caption: this we have learnt our toxic developers
Caption: communal shape and sizes to expand on
Caption: this a little bit I would like to
Caption: introduce you to some of them first
Caption: person I'd like to introduce you to is
Caption: alice alice is missing regularly come
Caption: Monday morning
Caption: you can almost bet that there will be an
Caption: email in your inbox from Alice saying
Caption: hey I won't be in today and when alice
Caption: is in and you walk past her desk you
Caption: don't see a code editor there's nothing
Caption: related to work there's like a browser
Caption: open with social media or any kind of
Caption: chat program clearly Alice is not
Caption: working as hard as everyone else in the
Caption: office yet when it comes to opinions and
Caption: Alice has always something to say about
Caption: what's going on in the office even
Caption: though it might not be her
Caption: responsibility however it comes and it
Caption: comes to delivering the actual piece of
Caption: work Alice isn't there imagine this
Caption: going on for week after week after week
Caption: and nothing changes clearly you might
Caption: find that Alice's lack or lack of
Caption: motivation starts to mess with your own
Caption: motivation the second person is Bob Bob
Caption: does an amazing job at pointing out and
Caption: finding the most mind and negative
Caption: things in someone's caught on a merge
Caption: request or a pull request even though
Caption: you might you know that this person was
Caption: putting up the pull request is still
Caption: learning and bob rarely offers any
Caption: actual real constructive feedback or
Caption: pointers towards resources and
Caption: documentation to learn and
Caption: improve for that person's still learning
Caption: over time some people may actually
Caption: become scared of putting a pull request
Caption: because they are afraid of the backlash
Caption: that could occur like comments raining
Caption: down on them there was a car hitting
Caption: this wrong with that room when
Caption: discussing work Bob doesn't like other
Caption: people's I'd like to hear other people's
Caption: ideas he likes to push his own ideas
Caption: forward if a project doesn't go the way
Caption: or in the direction that Bob likes he
Caption: may actually stop contributing or
Caption: becomes emotional about it and yet you
Caption: noticed that Bob doesn't doesn't seem to
Caption: treat everyone the same it depends
Caption: whether or not they agree with him last
Caption: but not least Charlie Charlie is a
Caption: manager when you have a meeting with
Caption: Charlie you share it and want to share
Caption: your ideas with Charlie or how to
Caption: improve the project are you working off
Caption: you find that charlie is dismissive and
Caption: doesn't want to hear you out here are
Caption: these are too hard to implement or just
Caption: not gonna work key things but a week
Caption: later when you find out that Charlie had
Caption: a meeting with his bosses and he clearly
Caption: has sold your ideas as his own suddenly
Caption: he gets all the praise for the thing
Caption: that you've come up with you put it down
Caption: as a once-off but then you learn over
Caption: time that it's actually the fact that
Caption: Charlie has done this time and time
Caption: again with ideas on people's ideas in
Caption: the organization now you're no longer
Caption: sure if he should be thinking of all
Caption: this stuff to improve the product that
Caption: you're on I should have spent time think
Caption: of different approaches or how to fix
Caption: things as you can see a lot of trees
Caption: these traits are quite connected to each
Caption: other before we move on though I'd like
Caption: to mention that I purely chose those
Caption: names to for me to remember them and
Caption: refer back to them later
Caption: it's hard to distinguish between a toxic
Caption: developer and someone who simply
Caption: disagrees with you or your team it's
Caption: important to acknowledge that people can
Caption: have bad days disagreements or simply
Caption: don't get well along along with each
Caption: other you peers may suffer from social
Caption: anxiety or our trust not good with
Caption: social interactions over time you will
Caption: discover that there's a certain patent
Caption: or actually it's just a once of
Caption: situation so it's super important to
Caption: remember difficult developers are not
Caption: necessarily toxic developers how are you
Caption: affected by a toxic developer when you
Caption: self-sacrifice what does that mean you
Caption: start changing the way you do things you
Caption: start naming things differently in a
Caption: code you follow this one person's advice
Caption: like you should be doing this way even
Caption: though you have done it the other way
Caption: for so many times so many years in your
Caption: career and this is the only person has a
Caption: problem with it up suddenly you try to
Caption: please that one person to avoid conflict
Caption: you and want to maintain peace you start
Caption: avoiding interaction if possible or you
Caption: resort to flattery where you compliment
Caption: someone a lot of things things with
Caption: input even though it may not actually
Caption: mean it and it actually goes to the it
Caption: could code towards a negative impact on
Caption: you and your work and to go on and that
Caption: is that you actually start doubting
Caption: yourself and your abilities like maybe
Caption: Bob is right maybe I haven't done enough
Caption: research maybe he knows better even
Caption: though I've been in this industry for 10
Caption: years I might be wrong or may not just
Caption: not good enough and to continue on with
Caption: that you may start feeling like quitting
Caption: like maybe goes on break maybe I'm not
Caption: good enough maybe I should go to a
Caption: different job or find a more suitable
Caption: job or reverse worry like ah I just
Caption: really don't want to deal with that
Caption: person
Caption: I may just create and find a better job
Caption: I should have nothing to do Peter you
Caption: mental health starts deteriorating and
Caption: that manifests itself example in trouble
Caption: sleeping when you go home after work
Caption: you carry all that stuff and you're
Caption: thinking about how what did let's say
Caption: this morning or what did Bob say that
Caption: pull request is today you're taking it
Caption: with you to bed and that leads to the
Caption: next day where you're lacking
Caption: concentration you having trouble like
Caption: thinking about solutions you effectively
Caption: lose your efficiency and when you think
Caption: about driving into work in the morning
Caption: or public transport whatever you
Caption: preferred methods of transport is you
Caption: suddenly feel like fearful you thinking
Caption: about how long is it gonna take until I
Caption: have to deal with Alice or Bob or
Caption: Charlie how long until they have a
Caption: comment that I complete negatively
Caption: impacts me and you feel stressed out
Caption: even though there's no clear deadline or
Caption: any current heavy workload you just kind
Caption: of feeling very stressed out and also
Caption: you know these changes in your
Caption: environment you imagine a busy lunch
Caption: room you have lunch with your colleagues
Caption: you're having a big chat Bob enters the
Caption: room everyone suddenly goes quiet the
Caption: conversation fizzles out and once that's
Caption: leaving think about your team chat
Caption: there's being fired for a while a toxic
Caption: developer puts something toxic
Caption: potentially into the chat it doesn't
Caption: even have to be toxic
Caption: it's just something and no one comments
Caption: and no one says anything hours pass a
Caption: day passes there's no reactions unless
Caption: they are prompted to response no one
Caption: wants to interact with them think about
Caption: emails unanswered meeting meetings kind
Caption: of weird because no one was really tough
Caption: to have anyone's problems and pull
Caption: requests unreviewed just anything to
Caption: avoid having to deal with the toxic
Caption: developer so people go quiet
Caption: if you may have to check started the way
Caption: to change things the way you do stuff
Caption: and you notice that in other people that
Caption: are tiptoeing around a certain person
Caption: you notice that behavior change as well
Caption: they want to please a certain person and
Caption: the other thing is that people come in
Caption: consistent so a certain person may deal
Caption: happily with you and it's friendly
Caption: towards you but any notice that they're
Caption: actually treating someone else in the
Caption: organization differently or that toxic
Caption: developer treats their team different
Caption: than your team that's all kind of ways
Caption: people are trusting their behavior now
Caption: if you are in a material lead kind of
Caption: role think about what this does to your
Caption: team and their productivity it's not
Caption: really good for a workplace is it who
Caption: knows a heavy section if you find that
Caption: certain traits or behaviors could match
Caption: with what you're doing
Caption: there are some good news though here's
Caption: how you can deal the toxic developer
Caption: this third and last section of my talk
Caption: when I prepared it I made it for three
Caption: kinds of people the perpetrators the
Caption: victims and their neighbors when I first
Caption: heard about the concept of an enabler I
Caption: was like what no what is an enabler
Caption: let me explain enable is someone who
Caption: sees toxic behavior and does nothing a
Caption: bystander
Caption: it's a co-worker who chomps on toxic
Caption: behavior and give amplifies the voice
Caption: and give them a voice even it's also a
Caption: manager who does nothing when issues are
Caption: reported to them and that last kind of
Caption: point is quite important when you
Caption: consider that by doing nothing the
Caption: enabler B could become the perpetrator
Caption: in the eyes of the victims so my advice
Caption: is focus your energy on what you can
Caption: control build resilience remember your
Caption: priorities and don't sell sacrifice
Caption: the things you're doing stop it doesn't
Caption: help anyone doesn't help your team
Caption: doesn't help you doesn't help your
Caption: organization don't change the way you do
Caption: things because of one person's opinion
Caption: and think about the way you react to
Caption: comments or toxic comments like poor
Caption: requests comments like ah you're doing
Caption: this wrong that's wrong
Caption: you're wrong don't be reactive and it's
Caption: easy for our responses to become too
Caption: emotional rather than illogical so
Caption: choose your battles wisely and stand
Caption: your ground when the time is right or in
Caption: other words know when to let something
Caption: go and when to make a point or push your
Caption: points rather if you see toxic behavior
Caption: going on challenge that behavior ask
Caption: questions like how would you fix
Caption: something you can't just say it's broken
Caption: and everything is bad how do you fix it
Caption: how do you improve something ask
Caption: questions
Caption: don't just let them do what I do and
Caption: don't become the enabler that's also
Caption: very important in challenging that so
Caption: don't amplifier my voice and if you have
Caption: done your research and you have put a
Caption: piece of work up and logic question or
Caption: poor guessing people are reviewing it
Caption: you've done your research you've looked
Caption: at the documentation you read the
Caption: manuals whatever tool you're using you
Caption: kind of feel like this is the best I
Caption: could do this is the pattern that a lot
Caption: of people are using and you still get
Caption: that toxic comments like how you doing
Caption: the wrong thing I know better but
Caption: there's no links or anything fight
Caption: opinion in fact post those links put
Caption: them in to modulus say hey this is what
Caption: I used this is what I'm basing my my
Caption: work on and look other people have done
Caption: the right the same thing as well I don't
Caption: see anything wrong with it and how
Caption: important also is stick with your
Caption: passion don't let anyone's insecurities
Caption: mess with what you're doing south
Caption: carries key focus is on yourself and
Caption: your work again you just really want to
Caption: think about what you're doing not what
Caption: this other person is doing or in fact
Caption: not doing it surround yourself with
Caption: mentors
Caption: who might have gone through this
Caption: themselves they can uplift you and they
Caption: can give you advice or different
Caption: perspectives of how to do or how to deal
Caption: with something and if you know that
Caption: sorry that's this one and if we know
Caption: that you have something going on at home
Caption: something is going with the family
Caption: currently and you're busy your head is
Caption: not in the right space announce it let
Caption: people know hey everyone I have all this
Caption: stuff going on at home and I know I'm
Caption: bringing it to work but be gentle with
Caption: me or I need some time or I just have
Caption: this stuff going on announce it set the
Caption: scene and you might be surprised other
Caption: people actually come up to you and want
Caption: to support you and help you get a good
Caption: night's sleep while you're waiting for
Caption: so well a lot of times feelings change
Caption: sorry it takes time to turn a ship
Caption: around a hundred eighty degrees nothing
Caption: happens fast and why are you waiting
Caption: get a good night's sleep it's very
Caption: important for your brain to reset and
Caption: after you go home from work and you
Caption: process all that stuff that happened
Caption: during the day be a positive influence
Caption: in your environment raise issues with
Caption: your team leader manager they may out be
Caption: able to offer a different perspective or
Caption: give you advice on how to deal with
Caption: something as well and if you see toxic
Caption: behavior impacting people in your team
Caption: support them talk to them let them know
Caption: hey I saw what's going on I want to help
Caption: you what can I do to help you support
Caption: your teammates and again if you see
Caption: something going on or impacting you
Caption: rather than just reading the comment on
Caption: a motor quest and be like hey no you're
Caption: wrong as well and jump on this massive
Caption: argument don't do that just remove
Caption: misinterpretation by going to that
Caption: person's desk if you can between the
Caption: same building
Caption: don't let toxic developers hind behind
Caption: the screen communication is key these
Caption: are all ways to improve your situation
Caption: think of your own waste improving
Caption: situation your ideas and solutions
Caption: actually might help other people
Caption: don't expect changes tomorrow next week
Caption: or a month it takes time to term
Caption: something that's gone bad around it's
Caption: hot is hard to change a habit after all
Caption: a toxic developer may still be able to
Caption: add value to your product projects it's
Caption: important to have good self care manage
Caption: and monitor your own behaviors because
Caption: that's what actually you actually can
Caption: control we can all take responsibility
Caption: in identifying toxic behavior within our
Caption: organizations it's not just HR or
Caption: management that can do something about
Caption: them it's the people that were closest
Caption: to be the top seed developer that are
Caption: affected the most that's right when I
Caption: came across when I visitors for my staff
Caption: talk I came across this awesome quote by
Caption: Gina Trapani oops and on a real to you a
Caption: lot of blustering hyperbole and personal
Caption: insults magically disappear when you're
Caption: talking into a real human being instead
Caption: of dumping wicked thoughts into a
Caption: glowing box I found it quite matching
Caption: one last thing I don't mean to create an
Caption: angry mob by giving this talk I want to
Caption: raise awareness because awareness gives
Caption: us power and talking about it let's just
Caption: feel less alone so please be nice to
Caption: each other and if you want to keep
Caption: adding comments or adding value to my
Caption: topic please use the hashtag toxic
Caption: deaths as it's down there in the corner
Caption: thank you very much for your time
Caption: [Applause]